العلاقات الروسيه الصينيه اكتسبت زخما
مضاعفا في ظل المحاولات الغربيه لعزل
الاقتصاد الروسي وهو ما دفع موسكو
مشاهدينا لتوجيهي حيز كبير من اقتصادها
نحو الصين قبل اسابيع من بدايه الحرف في
اوكرانيا لوحه الرئيسان روسي والصيني
بشراكه غير محدوده بين الدولتين للظهور
كاثقل موازن للغرب التبادلات التجاريه
تكثفت رغم العقوبات على روسيا وبلغ حجم
التجاره الثنائيه العمل الماضي 190 مليار
دولار وهو ما يعد رقم قياسيا ايضا ارتفعت
حصه اليوان في العملات المستخدمه في
التجاره الخارجيه الروسيه من نصف المائه
الى 16% في اسواق الطاقه زادت موسكو وتيره
التصدير للصين التي اصبحت هي والهند سوقي
تصدير رئيسيين لنفطر سي اضافه لتركيا ايضا
ومع خروج عشرات الشركات الغربيه من روسيا
وواجهت الحركه عبره تاخيرا بسبب عمليه
تفتيش الشحنات من قبل حرس الحدود الروسي